[Music]
glass shatters a d-class screams the
shill cry of an alarm sounds there's
been a containment breach at the scp
foundation somehow the plague doctor has
escaped his cell and is making a break
for it against all odds he finds the
exit and he's out he's free he's on the
lamb but how long can he elude the
foundation's attempts to track him down
and recontain him at any cost it will
take all of his cunning his intellect
and his strange anomalous abilities but
he's going to try and hold on to his new
found freedom as tightly as he can i'm
getting ahead of myself here though
let's start at the beginning day one
scp-04 or the plague doctor may be an
esoteric anomaly whose grasp of medicine
is practically medieval but he's still a
doctor he didn't get this far by not
paying attention to his surroundings so
when an unexpected power outage
triggered by an experiment gone wrong
somewhere in the bowels of site 19 gave
him the chance to escape captivity well
he took it the foundation had recently
revoked his access to live experimental
subjects again and he had had enough it
was time to seize the moment and make a
mad dash for freedom with the security
system down the doctor broke open the
door to his cell grabbed his trusty
apothecary bag and ran into the hall
guards were already swarming ready to
drag him back into captivity but he had
planned ahead swiftly he uncorked a
glass bottle of silvery liquid spilling
it onto the floor where it began to eat
away at the tile the shoes of the guards
and if they maintain contact for too
long
the soles of their feet this bought him
just enough time to keep running the
sounds of screaming down another hall
and the raucous laughter of one dr jack
bright signaled to the doctor that most
of the foundation staff were otherwise
occupied with this in mind he sprinted
on letting his chitinous body carry him
to the exit then for the first time in
far too long fresh air on his beak the
sun in his eyes the scent of cut grass
and damp leaves from the last night's
reign the world was here
waiting for him just as he had left it
of course the world was still very much
in danger he hadn't just broken free for
himself but to address the pestilence
head on as best as he could but for now
as he heard the sound of the alarm the
guards gaining on him he had to
prioritize his own safety first he had
to hide day two he ran for ages he
couldn't be quite sure how long as he
had no way to measure the passage of
time except the position of the sun in
the sky it set it rose bathing the
countryside in soft yellow light and set
again plunging the land into darkness
all while he continued to run then
finally the plague doctor stopped he had
found a farm there was a little
farmhouse but he did not dare disturb
the sleeping family and alarm them
instead he turned to the barn for
shelter he let himself in tipped out
past the horses as they slept there and
made himself a bed from straw and a
burlap sack from his bag he pulled a
pillow and a little spray bottle he
misted the pillow with a lavender
scented oil and finally allowed himself
a moment to rest he did not need to
sleep like ordinary men but after such a
long journey he could get pretty close
day three the morning of the plague
doctor's third day of freedom began with
a high-pitched winnie of a terrified
horse and the frantic stamping of hooves
the doctor opened his eyes to the sight
of one of the horses now awake and not
at all happy to see a stranger in its
barn making its fear and displeasure
known buttercup a man called from
outside the barn that you girl what's
got you spooked the door to the barn
creaked open and before the doctor could
do anything he was face to face with the
farmer who owned the land who are you
what are you doing in my barn the man
demanded good sir i apologize for the
intrusion i am but a humble traveler
seeking shelter you need to get out of
here and stop scaring my horses now
don't make me come back with my shotgun
no need for that sort of thing
i would be on my way the doctor
collected his things and decided to
spare the old farmer rather than use
more extreme methods to change his mind
he left the barn in a hurry day four day
four with the farm far behind him the
plague doctor trudged along on his
journey always keeping an eye out for
unmarked vans and armed guards so far
though he was safe he hadn't had a spare
moment to return to his experiments
though which was beginning to wear on
him the work was what had motivated him
to break out in the first place and now
he wasn't sure when he would be able to
make time for it cruel irony indeed but
then as if his silent prayer had been
answered he heard a peculiar sound
coming from the woods just off the dirt
road he was walking down a sickly bray
from an injured animal a poor soul in
need a patient he followed the sound to
its source a deer lay on its side
clearly sick or injured somehow do not
be afraid my friend the doctor said
softly you are sick but i can make you
well he sat his bag down on the grass
and got to work first he touched the
deer with a gloved hand stopping its
heart and putting it out of its misery
then he reached into his bag for his
trusty tools and some of his best
medicines in no time at all the deer was
reanimated cured walking around again
like new sure it was a little bit
different stumbling a bit and each eye
looking in a different direction but the
doctor considered the treatment a
success a day well spent day five the
next day feeling reinvigorated after his
successful encounter with the deer the
plague doctor began his quest for
shelter anew he walked for most of the
day until as the sun was setting he came
upon something curious a house
dilapidated looking with a large sign
out front reading house of horrors enter
if you dare though he didn't know it the
doctor had stumbled upon the local
town's premier seasonal haunted house
attraction to him it was simply an empty
house he could take up residence inside
he was curious and a bit perplexed as he
walked past plastic skeletons
animatronic werewolves that popped out
from behind styrofoam tombstones and
giant fake spiders and cotton cobwebs
none of the fake monsters gave him
trouble so though he was confused by
what he saw he continued to explore the
house then he found something incredible
a laboratory there was a long stainless
steel table with a mannequin strapped to
it a row of prop surgical tools sat on a
train next to the mannequin and along
the back shelf were rows and rows of
jars filled with liquids that looked
like something the play doctor himself
would pull out of his bag he couldn't
believe his eyes after wandering
aimlessly for days he found the perfect
place almost as if it had been made just
for him of course it wasn't it was for
the paying customers who would be coming
to the haunted house the next day along
with the actors hired to perform inside
but he didn't need to know any of that
yet he replaced the jars with his own
and the tools with functioning ones with
the exception of the plastic body on the
table which he privately wished was a
real human subject
this was absolutely perfect day six the
haunt actors showed up for work and were
surprised to find a new guy had beat
them there and he was already in costume
they shrugged it off they were making
minimum wage and that wasn't enough to
ask any questions they were there to
suit up and get spooky and that was it
they did appreciate his plague doctor
costume though it was much higher budget
than anything they had did you make that
get up yourself asked a friendly zombie
indeed i did the doctor replied
cheerfully happy to finally encounter a
group of individuals who were unafraid
of him nice bro the zombie gave him a
thumbs up and if the plague doctor could
with his rigid beaked face he would have
smiled these new colleagues were a bit
unusual looking with their ghostly white
faces vampire fangs green tinged makeup
and excess fur but their kindness was
encouraging meanwhile the haunt actors
were gossiping amongst themselves
wondering where the new plague doctor
character came from who approved it who
hired this guy why was he doing that
accent whatever he was whatever he was
plenty scary and nice enough guy to get
to work with so frankenstein's monster
let the plague doctor have the
laboratory set and moved himself into
the graveyard the customers loved him
too shrieking with delight as he
welcomed them into his laboratory asking
if any of them would like to volunteer
to be a test subject lucky for them they
had already been warned not to touch any
of the actors while walking through the
attraction as his first night at his
unintentional job came to a close the
plague doctor's new friends bit him
farewell we're gonna go to a bar up the
road for a couple drinks the ghostly
bride said wanna come ah no time for
revelry the plague doctor replied i must
attend to my work take care the woman
just laughed okay see you later and so
the plague doctor spent his night in the
haunted house again tinkering with his
tools and his tissue samples listening
to the royalty-free scary music tape
play again and again on repeat into the
night day seven the next day attendance
at the haunted house was slow the actors
with little to do spent their time
scrolling aimlessly on their phones
filming joke videos for social media and
pranking each other one of them got the
bright idea to pull a prank on the new
hire the stranger that none of them knew
much about he would have a friend turn
out the lights in the laboratory and
when the lights were turned back on he
would have replaced the mannequin on the
table he couldn't have known what would
happen all he wanted to do was startle
the new guy freak him out with the sight
of an unexpected werewolf on his
operating table and it was effective
sort of the plague doctor froze in place
when the lights went out calling hello
what is happening and when the room was
illuminated once more he took in the
sight of the living being on the
operating table my friend you've come to
me for treatment the werewolf started to
get up disappointed he hadn't managed to
elicit a scream but the plague doctor
reached out a hand to stop him and that
was curtains for that particular actor
as soon as the plague doctor's gloved
hand made contact with the man in the
werewolf costume his heart stopped oh
dear the plague doctor remarked do not
fear i have the cure you'll be all right
in no time at all by the time the rest
of the actors came to see what had
happened to the werewolf there was a
real zombie in the haunted house
then it was pure chaos actors running
and screaming knocking over props and
abandoning their seasonal gig darting
between customers as they went shrieking
don't go in there it's real naturally
this only made them want to check it out
even more but by the time they got
inside there was no sign of the plague
doctor only one very lost zombie in a
werewolf costume a few jars broken in
all the chaos and footsteps in the dry
grass outside leaving town days 8 to 18.
the plague doctor spent all of his
eighth day on the run walking once more
he was starting to get used to this the
endless drudgery of the path to freedom
he hated to admit it but he was almost
starting to miss his cell back at the
foundation the routine of it the quiet
time to work the three meals given to
him each day even though he didn't need
to eat to survive he missed food and
drink the simple pleasures of bread meat
cheese fruit a mug of tea a cup of wine
he sighed to himself wistfully then he
caught a whiff of something lovely he
lifted his beak taking in another deep
breath the unmistakable scent of roast
pheasant hearty and warm beneath it
something else mulled wine spiced and
inviting smells that reminded him of
home of days long lost he couldn't be
certain where it would lead or if there
would be a seat for him at the table but
he couldn't resist following the
heavenly aroma to its source as he drew
closer to the smell of food and
merriment he could hear music the
plucking of a liar the high trill of a
flute singing and clapping then he
finally spotted it rows of colorful
tents long banquet tables minstrels
wandering about and playing ballads to
anyone who would listen men women and
children frolicking in elaborate
costumes plate armor robes gowns and
more though the plague doctor didn't
know how to describe what he was seeing
he had wandered onto the site of one of
the state's largest renaissance fairs it
just so happened to be opening day and
he was just in time for the celebratory
feast good day doctor a nobleman tipped
his hat to scp-049
are you speaking to me the plague doctor
was taken aback by the recognition why
of course you're the only doctor i see
her majesty the queen thanks you for
your service for keeping us all safe
from the great plague the plain doctor
had no idea that this man was an actor
playing along with him in what he
assumed was a scene for the tourists
instead he took the words to heart
swelling with pride and gratitude for
the recognition good sir it is my duty
and my honor the plague doctor nodded
politely luckily for him an unbeknownst
to the rest of the cast of players at
the fair the man originally hired to
play the town plague doctor had booked a
commercial role that morning and decided
not to go in to work the man's choice
not to call and let anyone know though
rude led to a fortuitous
misunderstanding for scp-049
please join us at the royal table the
nobleman made a sweeping gesture with
his arm inviting the doctor to sit and
dine with him and the rest of the actors
playing members of the court thank you
for your kindness if he could the plague
doctor would have smiled he died to his
heart's content that afternoon listening
to sounds of music and laughter he
slotted into his role at the fair even
better than his position at the haunted
house he answered questions from
tourists about his work as a physician
warned them of the dangers of the great
pestilence and posed for the occasional
photograph he spent a wonderful 10 days
living in a stylized artificial version
of the past basking in the warm glow of
camaraderie though the other actors
wondered why he never took his mask off
even to eat then sadly it was time for
the fair to pack up for the season the
plague doctor bid his new friends
farewell and declined their offers to
exchange numbers and keep in touch he
would however always remember them
fondly days 19 through 41 as he was
departing the fairgrounds the doctor
caught a glimpse of strange men
approaching some of the actors showing
federal badges and asking them questions
he couldn't be certain that it was the
foundation but it was more than enough
to make him cautious he would have to
retreat into the woods once more and
stay out of sight he laid low for quite
some time for 22 days to be exact but
then on day 41 day 41 to 52 it started
to snow white blanketed the forest floor
soft and cold the weather wouldn't kill
him of course but it was uncomfortable
he would need to find some more
efficient shelter to escape from the
elements before the winter storm
worsened he trudged through the snow
into a new town small and quaint there
was an abandoned church at the edge of
the main road a bit broken down but the
roof held firm against the onslaught of
ice and wind so the plague doctor made
it his new home for the next 12 days
working quietly and staying out of sight
day 53-57
on the eve of the plague doctor's 53rd
day on the run from the scp foundation
he was stirred from his work by the
sound of a choir of beautiful voices
outside he looked to find a group of
christmas carolers singing together the
rows of houses along the streets covered
in colorful lights and glittering
decorations wanting to get a little
closer to the music the doctor left his
hiding spot for the first time in nearly
two weeks but as the choir saw a
strangely shaped dark shadow emerging
from the abandoned church they screamed
and scattered in every direction one of
them yelled something about the krampus
as they went frightened by the whole
interaction scp-049 found himself a new
spot under a bridge it was cold but
isolated at least it was for five days
day 58 on day 58 a group of local
teenagers rowdy and looking to make some
trouble spotted the plague doctor
squatting under the bridge they pelted
him with snowballs laughing before he
could do anything about it fortunately
for the teens they then ran back to
their car and sped away drenched in ice
and cold water miserable and irritated
the plague doctors searched for another
place to stay day 59 to day 84. the
plague doctor was able to slip into
another relatively quiet building the
local community theater which happened
to be an old opera house repurposed as
the site of volunteer-run musicals while
the townsfolk began rehearsals for the
production of the phantom of the opera
the plague doctor watched from above
hiding in the shadows every so often the
stagehand would catch a glimpse of a
cape the silhouette of a face a pair of
dark eyes but no one believed her when
she tried to tell them that the phantom
was real at least until a handyman went
up into the rafters to install some
lights and saw the plague doctor for
himself then it was time for him to flee
to a new town day 85 to day 89 on day 85
the plague doctor climbed up onto the
roof of a dark house to avoid a
particularly aggressive dog and let
himself in through the attic window the
next morning a little girl came up into
the attic in search of a lost toy and
found him there he waited for her to
scream but she didn't she introduced
herself as abby and asked if he would
like some cookies and milk he accepted
her gracious offer and the two visited
with each other for several days until
abby's parents asked who she was talking
to they didn't take it well when she
answered the birdman in the attic day
90. on day 90 abby's parents called the
police who had been warned to look out
for a man in a bird mask and got in
touch with their contacts at the scp
foundation feeling the authorities
closing in
scp-049 took to the wilderness once more
day 91 to day 99 though the air was
still painfully cold the plague doctor
managed to set up camp using tools from
his bag to build a fire and construct a
makeshift tent he stayed there for three
days before intending to move on and
throw the foundation off of his trail
but he was slowed by the appearance of a
group of hikers bundled up against the
winter weather and exploring the woods
afraid he couldn't trust them the doctor
touched one to convince him to leave the
man fell to the ground dead and as his
companions ran away screaming the doctor
vowed to cure him working against the
inopportune conditions it took him five
more days to reanimate the hiker on day
100 of his time on the lamb the
foundation finally closed in the plague
doctor was just stitching up a large
incision in his patient's chest when he
heard the click of a gun behind him come
with us peacefully and we won't have to
sedate you the officer said with a heavy
side the plague doctor held up his hands
stepping back from his patient just as
its undead body sat up blinking its
unseeing eyes very well i will go back
to tell you the truth gentlemen this has
all been a bit too much trouble i could
use the rest now go check out scp-049
the plague doctor captured and scp-049
cures scp-096 of the pestilence for more
of your favorite mysterious mask doctor